good afternoon everybody
[Music]
today the vice president is in Memphis
Tennessee to attend the celebration of
life service for Tyree Nichols White
House officials including senior advisor
for public engagement Keisha Lance
bottoms and Senior advisor and
infrastructure coordinator Mitch Landry
are also in attendance on behalf of the
administration as you know the president
and the vice president spoke to Mr
nichols's mother and stepfather on the
phone earlier to express their
condolences and support
the president told Mr Nicholas's family
that he would continue pushing Congress
to send the George Floyd Justice and
policing act to his desk last year when
when Senate Republicans blocked that
legislation from coming to his desk
President Biden took executive action
but as the president has said there is
no substitute to Federal legislation
that's why tomorrow the president is
hosting representative horseford and a
small group of CBC members here at the
White House for a conversation about
George Floyd Justice and policing act
and other shared policies
and it's why he's continuing to call on
republicans in Congress to join with
Democrats and ensure our justice system
lives up to its name
I know you all just came back from the
president's competition council meeting
so I wanted to highlight a few a few
items that uh that has showed some
progress we've made on the president's
competition agenda today is Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau cfpb rule
would save consumers as much as nine
billion dollars a year in excessive
credit card late fees the ntia report
today provides recommendations to give
consumers more control over their
devices and the president is calling on
Congress to pass a junk fee prevention
act which would crack down on excessive
concert and entertainment ticket fees
ban Airline fees for families to sit
with young children eliminate exorbitant
early termination fees for a TV phone
and internet service ban surprise Resort
and destination fees at hotels and also
more broadly we are making progress
limiting junk fees which can cost
hundreds of dollars a month cfpb is
targeting overdraft and bounce back fees
reducing those fees by more than one
billion dollars a year and the
transportation department LED more
Airlines to guarantee coverage of hotels
and meals when flights are delayed or
canceled for issues under their control
competition is a core tenet of the
president's economic agenda to lower
prices and promote capitalism now
turning to another piece of news during
the North American leaders Summit
earlier this month President Biden
emphasized his commitment to working
with Mexico to prosecute Dangerous Drug
traffickers and increase information
sharing on chemicals used in in the
illicit manufacturing of Fentanyl and
other synthetic drugs yesterday the
treasury Department sanctioned leader of
a mexico-based network and two
Associates for procuring
precursor chemicals from China to
manufacture and traffic illicit Fentanyl
and other synthetic drugs to the United
States this action was coordinated
closely with the government Mexico and
will play a role in disrupting the
importation of chemicals to the United
States and we will continue to closely
coordinate with Mexico or and our
regional Partners to disrupt the
transnational criminal organizations
that are trafficking illicit fentanyl
into the United States and I wanted to
end
our topper here by Mark by marking the
start of Black History Month which we
are celebrating today each February
National Black History Month serves as
both a celebration and a powerful
reminder that black history is an
American history black history is
American culture black black stories are
essential to the ongoing story of
America yesterday the President issued a
proclamation in celebration of black
history month this month the Biden
Harris Administration is shining a light
on black history by taking time to
celebrate the immeasurable contributions
of black Americans honoring the legacies
and achievements of generations past
Reckoning with centuries of injustices
and confronting those injustices that
are still so vividly in front of us
today President Biden and vice president
Harris are deeply committed to advancing
Equity Rachel racial Justice and
opportunity for black Americans as this
Administration continues striving to
realize America's founding promise this
administration's commitment began with
building a federal government that looks
like America it continued with building
a federal bench that reflects our nation
nearly one-third of his judicial
appointments are black Americans and
President Biden has nominated more black
women to federal courts than ever than
every other president in history
combined and of course President Biden
appointed kataji Justice contagi Brown
Jackson the first black woman to serve
on our nation's highest court in the
land
and in just two years the Biden Harris
Administration has delivered real and
Lasting change and continues to work
each day to deliver Equitable outcomes
and opportunity for black Americans
whether it's rebuilding the economy
where the unemployment rate for black
Americans is a near-record historic low
at 5.7 percent or providing nearly 6
billion dollars in historic resources
and support for historically black
colleges and universities but of course
even as we make meaningful progress not
a day goes by and especially not this
day today without real reminders of how
far we have left to go
the Biden Administration will honor and
continue the work of black Americans who
have created a more fair and inclusive
democracy helping our nation move closer
to realization of its full promise of
opportunity and justice for all with
that song man
um I wanted one question on a police
reform can you talk about the
president's message to the CDC members
when he meets with them tomorrow and
what new sort of strategy the White
House has forgetting police reforms or
Congress and I ask that because one of
the CDC members told one of my
colleagues today that the president is
quote missing the opportunity to be a
historic president when it comes to
these issues and that he's been a
champion of the status quo in many ways
we need to be we need him to be as
champion of a new vision for America so
look the president is very much looking
forward to meeting with Congressional
the members of the Congressional Black
Caucus and to have a conversation a real
conversation about how to move forward
on police reform and other shared
policies as I mentioned moments ago look
these are members that the president has
had a long-standing relationship with as
you all know and it's uh it is a
collaboration that we see uh this this
conversation becoming a collaboration
again on dealing with an issue that is
truly affecting the black community and
also the brown Community as well and you
know to to your to the statement that
you just laid out from a congressional
uh Black Caucus member I would say this
you know and I said this at the top when
when the Senate Republicans blocked and
would not move forward with the George
Floyd policing act the president acted
he acted by moving forward within taking
executive action and that shows uh we
believe and the president believes how
important this issue is and by bringing
the Congressional Black Caucus tomorrow
to the White House it also shows the
president's commitment to working with
Congress on trying to figure out how do
we move forward again it does not take
away from the fact the way that we're
going to deal with this issue is to have
Federal legislation that's how we're
going to move forward again the
president took executive action he was
very proud that he was able to do that
when the senate senate Republicans in
particular blocked blocked what the what
Democrats were trying to do and he took
action and I think that shows his
commitment and undocumented Ian
addressed the version of this
go but I'm wondering how the White House
can claim that they are being
transparent when the FBI surge of the
Penn Center pendant Center that happened
months ago was not proactively disclosed
to the public and what should the public
take away from the fact that you are
keeping information like this from the
public look I'm going to be very prudent
from here I'm going to be very
consistent from here I'm just not going
to comment anything that is related to
what is currently happening this is a
legal process as you just mentioned my
colleague was right outside these doors
answering many of your questions he has
done that these past couple of weeks I
believe four weeks now and he'll
continue to do that anything that is
specific to this uh to this particular
process I would refer you to the
Department of Justice and also again my
colleagues at the White House counsel's
Office
following up on that I understand you're
not going to discuss the details or
anything but just is there a reason the
two of the searches were disclosed and
not the search of the Penn Biden Center
you mentioned this is a legal process is
there a legal reason why you're
disposing only two and not what we know
is a third search I'm again I'm going to
refer you to the White House council's
Office
[Music]
uh what does he hope to get out of this
meeting look we have said before the
president is looking forward to working
uh working closely and trying to figure
out how he can deliver uh with uh with
Republicans who are willing to work in a
you know in a good faith bipartisan way
he said that right after the midterm
elections and uh he's con he will
continue to make that effort and you
know the president has been very clear
about this he wants to they're going to
talk about a range of issues as you've
heard me say as you've heard us uh
really report out from how we see this
this meeting moving forward and look he
wants to hear from uh the speaker what's
his plan what is his plan on the budget
what is his plan to really deal with uh
to deal with um to deal with what is at
the top of the minds of the American
people how are we going to lower costs
for them how are we going to deal with
the national deficit which is something
that the president has taken very
seriously by AI in record in record
fashion lowering the deficit by 1.7
billion dollars he wants to talk about
that he's always willing to have those
conversations in good faith and also he
wants to see what their budget is what
is their plan we've heard them over and
over again talk about cutting Medicare
cutting Social Security this is what we
have heard from Republicans leading up
to the midterms and then after the
midterms so okay what what is what else
are they going to be doing what does
that look like for them if the president
did have some Choice words for the
speaker last night ahead of this meeting
he says he's made off-the-wall
commitments to the far right uh is there
any strategy and in saying that ahead of
this meeting uh is he trying to throw
him off a little bit or on the flip side
note is that really helpful to be
talking like that I will say this like
we understand what the speaker is going
through he has a caucus uh that uh you
know that has put forth some pretty
extreme ideas some extreme options in
front of the Amer American people
cutting Medicare cutting Social Security
that is what he's dealing with and so
what we're saying is uh that okay well
this is what your your caucus is saying
this is what your conference is saying
what's your plan and I think that's what
he is acknowledging really what the
speaker is currently dealing with uh but
look you know as we as we talk about uh
as you we talk about the meeting that's
about to come up very shortly and what
they're going to discuss again a range
of issues the president had meetings as
you know with the Democratic Leadership
just last week he's looking forward to
having this conversation you saw on memo
yesterday asking asking the speaker and
and really Congress republicans in
Congress are they going to live up to
their constitutional obligation are they
going to lift the debt ceiling as many
of them did including speaker McCarthy
three times under the last uh president
so that's number one their obligation
are they going to live up to that and
then number two what's their plan as it
relates to the budget and dealing with
issues that truly matter for the
American people
the president's president
I would refer you to the White House
council's Office Ian just declined to
comment on that
um
on on debt um would the President veto a
bipartisan bill that included both
spending cuts and a debt limit hike
similar to the 2011. so I'm not going to
get I'm certainly not going to well I'm
glad you you mentioned 2011 because I
know I there's been a lot of reporting
on that and I just want to be very clear
in 2011 the Obama Biden Administration
negotiated in good faith but
Congressional Republicans recklessness
recklessness caused a historic blow to
our economy that's what we saw in 2011
and that's why when you look at how the
administration the Obama Biden
Administration moved forward in 20 2013
and 2014 and 2015. they move forward in
a way to avoid uh unnecessary danger
they didn't do that in in those three in
those three consecutive years because of
the bad faith that they saw in 2011. and
so uh look let's not forget that's why
my congressional Democrats and
Republican in in Congress voted three
times in the Trump Administration to
lift the debt ceiling and let's not
forget this has happened 78 times since
1960 49 times under Republican
presidents and 29 times under uh
Democratic president so this has been
done before it's their constitutional
obligation to do this and we are talking
about programs when they talk about
Medicare and Social Security we're
talking about programs that they want to
take hostage that's going to affect
taxpayers that's going to affect seniors
that's going to affect veterans and
again it is their constitutional Duty
they should be able to do this without
conditions
history I'm trying to address some
Market related chatter as well as some
of the beliefs of some members on
Capitol Hill was just asked about the
debt ceiling he said there's only one
option here it's for Congress to pass
the increase is that the view of the
White House there is only one option
there are no prioritization off ramps
comically large coins to consider that
Congress is the only option here so on
any of the coins and mint coins I know
that's come up before you know that's
something that the treasury deals with
and and answers on so I'm not going to
comment there I think we've been very
very clear I think we've been very clear
from here that this should be done
without conditions and um
it is it is their basic job Congress
right is their basic duty to lift the
debt ceiling it is something that has
been consistently done over the years
and that's how we see it we see it as is
something that should not be done
without con with with conditions it
should be done without conditions to be
even clearer and again it is their
constitutional obligation to get this
done for the on behalf of the American
people I understand that and you guys
have made that abundantly clear
repeatedly I'm saying are you closing
can you close the door on any other
Alternatives than Congress
fulfilling their constitutional
look what I'm saying is we've been very
clear about when we've been asked if
there's going to be a negotiate if
there's room for negotiations we have
said this should be done without any
conditions which there should be a way
to go around this to get this done this
is something that Congress should act on
now and I've mentioned this a little bit
which is as it relates to uh you know
lowering the deficit and that being a
top priority for this President and has
been throughout the last two years he is
willing and happy to have a good faith
conversation with anybody who wants to
talk to him about ways to do that and
that's why he's been able to in the last
two years we've talked about it I just
mentioned it in record fashion 1.7 uh
trillion dollars which is the largest
decline in American history that's what
the president has been able to do now as
it relates to the debt ceiling that is a
separate matter that is a different
different matter we see this as a
constitutional obligation that they that
they have that Congress has to act just
one more um the department of interior
Advanced uh an eight billion oil drone
project earlier today climate Advocates
uh had pretty sharp criticism of that
does the president believe he was
adequately balancing his climate goals
with the need for increased oil
production so let me just be clear no
decision has been made on this uh so I
now if you're asking about the
president's commitment to tackling
climate crisis as I think you were just
saying the president has done more than
any other president uh on this front and
he's taken bold executive actions to
accelerate clean energy manufacturing
he's secured historic legislation to
make communities more resilient to the
impacts of climate change and lower
energy costs and so much more and he
continues to deliver on historic climate
change action while carrying out the law
and meeting our energy needs again no
decision has been made yet this is
something as it relates to this
particular project the final decision is
going to be made by the Secretary of the
Interior but this is a president that
has been committed to climate change and
and uh and you see that again in his
actions
uh thank you um you were mentioning
police reform how uh the president has
said that he wants legislative action it
doesn't seem like there's more momentum
at this point uh for the George Floyd
bill is there anything being considered
as far as executive action I realize he
signed the order last summer but
anything additional as far as executive
action let me let me just say a couple
of things here because I think people
forget what the executive action did and
that the president took again he took
these the he took this step when Senate
Republicans blocked the George Floyd uh
uh policing act and would not move
forward with something that's incredibly
important so it if you look at the
executive action it resulted in
immediate changes like mandate mandating
stricter use of force standards and body
worn cameras and banning it banned
chokeholds and restricting no knock
warrants at the federal level it set the
new standard for Effective accountable
policing at the federal at the federal
level as well it also in incentivize
incentivizes reform at the state and
local level through Grant making and
accreditation standards but again we
understand there's a lot more work to do
and the way that we're seeing this the
way that the president sees this in
order to have long lasting change we
have to have Federal legislation that is
the way that we're going to be able to
see real a real difference in
communities as it relates to police
reform and that's why he's having the
caucus here he's going to have those
conversations and see how how we can
move forward there were some things that
were revised in that in that order
compared to earlier draft orders they're
on use of force it originally said that
officers would only be able to use
deadly force as a last resort that was
changed to when necessary as well so it
did revise but there were additional
things that some criminal justice
Advocates were calling for as well so is
there anything additionally noting
what's in there that's being considered
in case we don't see Congress move so
again
we the president has taken this very
seriously by putting forward an
executive action as you just laid out we
talked we went back and forth and talked
about what was in the executive action
but he truly believes in order to make
real reform here we have to get Congress
to act and we this is a president that
has been told many times you cannot get
this done you cannot get that done and
we have you know and if you look at the
last two years you know I think more
than 250 pieces of legislation that
became into law were bipartisan some of
the most important historical pieces of
legislation that it's going to really
help Americans as we talk about the
economy as we talk about not leaving
anybody behind behind was done in a
bipartisan way think about the
bipartisan infrastructure legislation
right for example you think about the
chips and science act that's bringing
back manufacturing manufacturing back
into the into the US those are important
steps that was led by this President so
again it's not going to stop him just
because we're we may be hearing
naysayers or people are saying that we
are not going to get this done doesn't
mean that the president is not going to
continue to work really really hard to
make this happen there's one more does
he support a pattern in practice
investigation into the Memphis Police
Department uh I'm just not going to get
into any specifics as to what's
happening currently in Memphis as you
know there's an ongoing investigation
there's an injustice that would be look
that's I will the Department of Justice
is dealing with and uh they're doing
their own investigation as we know
authorities are doing their own uh
investigation we're just not going to
comment on anything specifics as as that
is going on
uh would the White House be open to an
Appropriations deal that also takes care
of the debt limit or would that in your
view be negotiating on it in some way
well we said again without conditions
this should be done and lifted without
conditions uh and that would be a a way
to get around of doing their
constitutional Duty so I'll just leave
it there
[Music]
why not have Ian brief in here
uh well Ian was outside and took your
questions
outside and took your question and he's
been doing that for the last four weeks
would the White House have revealed
today's search if pool cameras hadn't
caught the investigators arriving on
scene again this is a question for the
White House counsel's office I would
refer you to them
um today is perhaps the best example yet
of
the new era of divided government when
there were Republican oversight hearings
being held today into the
administration's border security and
pandemic policy president's meeting with
the speaker you remind us what is the
level of cooperation or
legitimate uh back and forth you're
willing to have with a republican-led
house when they're holding these
investigations
see that say a little bit more sorry
okay border security policy is one thing
pandemic policy how money was spent is
another uh what what does the White
House consider to be the kind of
oversight and increase from
congressional committees that you're
willing to engage in and what is not so
look as it relates to the oversight
committee and I've said this many times
before look we're willing to work with
Republicans House Republicans on
important priorities that matter to the
American people like lowering uh
lowering uh costs for for Americans as
they said was really important going
into the midterm elections that's what
we want to focus on we want to focus on
the priorities that matter to the
American people we're not interested in
engaging in political stunts and we want
to move past the constant political
Warfare as we continue to see from
Republican sadly and again let's not
forget when Americans went out to vote
for in the midterms they said they
wanted to see less of that they actually
wanted to see bipartisan citizenship as
it relates to any specifics to the
oversight committee I would refer you to
my colleagues at the White House
council's office there was a local news
report that various versions of the
so-called East that the president is
driven around in don't include the
taxation without representation license
plates that presidents Bill Clinton and
Barack Obama used and presidents Bush
and Trump did not is there any reason
for that or does the president plan to
so I saw I saw some of those uh some of
that reporting you have like I know you
have look he just looked over at Mary
Mary looked over to you and I don't know
what's happening
um but uh look I have to run down that
down as to uh the Beast and and why it
may not have those plates but what I can
tell you in the present has been very
consistent since the campaign that we
strongly support the DC statehood and uh
and that has not changed but I'll run
that down to see about the plates on the
Beast and January came and went and
there was no physical for the president
is there a plan for that that is a very
good question I'm glad you asked it uh
so
um just to answer that question for you
the president will physical will be
completed February 16th and released
publicly in the same manner as it was
back in 2021 so we have a date for you
wanted to make sure we had a date for
you
yes uh uh and just to just to give you a
little bit more of information I know
folks were wondering why it hasn't
happened yet this was literally a matter
of scheduling around what has been an
incredibly uh busy uh busy schedule for
the president the past several months uh
evolving schedule travel schedule in
recent weeks as you've all have seen for
yourself but we have a date in the books
and so wanted to share that with all of
you
thank you uh
I'll ask you about the india-us
initiative of critical and emergency
technology situate launched yesterday uh
NSS Sullivan said that it is the next
big step in the relationship and he also
said that this is initiative led by
President himself can you let us know
what this person thinks about it why
he's launching the initiative and why
this is called the big next big thing in
this relationship so as you know the
president and uh and the Prime Minister
Prime Minister Modi announced this
initiative back when they met in a
meeting in May of just last year 2022
and that was in Tokyo as you all know
and directed their National Security
advisors to spearhead our partnership in
critical emerging Technologies and the
president believes this initiative that
you just laid out is key for the US and
India to create a democratic technology
ecosystem and reinforces our democratic
values and our Democratic institution so
we see this as a incredibly important
initiative and a partnership that we
have with India we made our
announcements yesterday in in defensive
Innovation semiconductors space 5G and
stem talent and we look forward to to
building on this momentum in the
upcoming months and years so again an
important partnership and initiative
between the two uh the two uh friends
who are to two countries so it also aim
towards China
at contacts that we live in as you ask
me about China but this initiative is
not about one any country or one country
it truly is about uh something bigger
than that a relationship between uh two
friends two countries who have been
partners for some time so look as two
two of the world's leading economies and
democracies it is in our interests to
strengthen this partnership and deliver
for our people and when you think about
the economies and the people around the
world so we think this is an important
step forward and will continue to grow
on this Invasion initiative thank you
um one more on the deficit reduction
talks as it relates to the debt limit so
is the position of the white house that
you don't want to negotiate obviously in
the debt limit that needs to happen you
say Congress needs to do that without
conditions so would that mean that any
bipartisan proposal that the president
agreed to is it relates to deficit
reduction or debt reduction would have
to happen after Congress raised the debt
limit well I mean
I guess I'm just trying to figure out
the process here like what's step one
and what's step two and I don't think
there's just one step and the step is
they need to live up to their
Congressional obligation that's their
constitutional obligation to be even
more specific which is lifting the debt
ceiling something that was done three
times under the last president and I've
mentioned the number 78 many times
because it's happened 78 times since
1960s 49 times under uh Republican
president 29 times under a Democratic
president this is something that the
speaker himself voted on three times in
the last Administration so there's only
one step here and the one step is to do
this without conditions the president
has said and you have said from this
Podium that he is open to these
negotiations and potential legislation
right on deficit and debt right well
we're talking about the national deficit
when we're talking about lowering that
the president is willing to have good
faith conversation which is something
that he's prioritized right we've talked
we mentioned the 1.7 billion dollars
that he was able to lower the deficit
and because of the economic policies
that he's moved forward with so he takes
that very very seriously now if they
want to have a good faith conversation
about that he's willing to listen but
right now all we have heard from the
Republicans the Republicans in the house
to be very specific the extreme
Republicans in the house to be even more
specific is that they want to cut
Medicare they want to cut Social
Security hold that hostage which is
something that should not be done it
would lead us into chaos so it's not
it's it's it is a a direction that we
think is wrong a direction that is not
should not be taken we think that when
it comes to the lifting the debt ceiling
it should be done without conditions
perform really quickly again for
again Senator Graham is voting the comp
a compromise idea that would keep
qualified immunity for officers but
would get rid of those protections for
police departments with the presence
support a compromise of that kind so I
haven't seen that uh that piece of
legislation who certainly would have to
uh go get go back to our policy team to
talk through that legislation from
Senator Graham what I will say though is
the president wants to see action in a
bipartisan way
in Congress to deal with an issue that's
clearly critical as we're watching
what's happening today we're watching a
family bury a loved one and we believe
he believes the way that we're going to
make transformational change on this
issue is to have legislation I don't
want to speak to something that I have
not spoken to the team it's possible the
George Floyd Justice and policing act it
doesn't have to come in the version that
it pre-existed did right you guys are
open to some changes is that is that a
yes I mean look if it's in a bipartisan
way if it's Republicans joining
Democrats in a real way to to bring
forth transformational change we are
willing to have that conversation look
tomorrow's caucus is going to be very
important as well and we're going to
talk to the CBC members and talk through
what their what their ideas are and what
they're thinking but again we think that
legislation Federal legislation is the
way to move forward here's another
question I asked this to be in Sam's
outside when he um took our questions
earlier I want to ask of you though
because I think it is for the wider
White House not just the special
counsel's office which is did anyone at
the White House tell the National
Archives at any point not to issue a
press release about the discovery of
classified documents I would really
refer you to the White House council's
Office who has been running this process
and refer you to them even if it's
something that's not just in their
purview would be wider with them for the
white house because this is when it when
it relates to the doj when it relates to
special counsel this is something that's
been under their purview so I would
refer you to them
crane I'm I'm the uh show up to work uh
telework bill
um I wanted to see if you could tell us
what the White House's position is on
that piece of legislation it seeks to
end telework for federal workers um so
they'll go back to work in downtowns
um and whether or not President Biden
would veto it should pass so a couple of
things I just want to take a little bit
of a step back and and kind of take us
back to when the president first walked
into this Administration and what he had
to do and was able to do was really do a
whole of government
process in dealing with a coven and what
we saw at the time and he put forth a
comprehensive
comprehensive way to deal with making
sure that people got their shots in arms
right making sure that what we saw with
schools being closed small businesses
being closed he was able to to move
forward with the American Rescue plan
which was only voted out of out of
Congress by democrats and what we were
able to do is open the country reopen
the country small businesses are booming
as we saw a record a record number of
small business applications that we
which we announced about two weeks ago
and now the kova 19 does not determine
how federal agencies work and serve the
public because of the work that this
President did on day one and so our view
is that the agency decisions should be
guided by a focus on delivering results
for the American people that's how they
should move forward like other major
employers and federal agencies are
making those decisions based on their
performance goals not only to increase
efficiency and Effectiveness but also to
remain competitive in the labor market
so we're committed to working with
anyone in Congress to continue
strengthening federal agencies we think
that's incredibly important and the
federal Workforce in order to deliver on
on their missions and serve the American
public that that's what we think the
criteria should be look you know we've
explained our thinking how the president
sees this and don't have anything to
share specifically on the the show up
act but we believe that you know there
are ways that eight federal agencies
should be able to track their
performance and continue to continue to
deliver for the American people and
that's how we think this is the most
important way to move forward here
there's particularly given the
administration announcing
[Music]
now I just don't have anything specific
it's on on on that particular questions
we again think it should be that
decision should be guided by agency that
that's their decision to make on one
other topic on Russia
um does the Biden Administration believe
that Russian and Belarusian athletes
should be able to compete in the Olympic
Games in Paris in 2024. so um I haven't
talked to the to my to my colleagues at
NSC would like to get a sense of where
they are have not heard any real like
reporting or had any incoming so let me
just talk to them and see where we are
with them
thanks Kareem a couple weeks ago when
the Mayors were in town the president
said he looked forward to an honest
debate with Republicans on entitlements
the house speaker on Sunday on Face the
Nation was asked if he was going to
propose cuts to Medicare and Social
Security and he said no he said he would
take that off the table he was asked
completely and he said yeah so is it
your sense is it the sense here that the
house speaker is not being honest when
he says that I I think it's more of like
there are some facts out there right
that we can easily point to like this
Administration can point to and I think
I did a little bit of that last time and
so if you look at uh McCarthy's
Republican conference especially the
extreme part of the of that conference
uh and and McCarthy himself voted to
raise the retirement age and and
Medicare as we know it that has been
historic like that is those are the
facts uh and just last year the
Republican study committee which
includes most House Republicans
reiterated those calls to cut Social
Security and Medicare when Republicans
call for these Cuts they do so under the
guise of strengthening the programs so
you know when when the speaker speaker
McCarthy says he wants to strengthen
Social Security or Medicare but rules
out making the wealthy and the big
corporations pay their fair share so
that leads just to one option which is
cuts and again many many outlets in here
reported what what House Republicans
were thinking about when it came to this
new Congress the new 118th Congress Fox
News says Republicans I using debt limit
hike to overhaul entitlement programs if
entrusted with majority that's something
that was reported on CBS Republicans
want to push Social Security Medicare
eligibility age to 70 as I just
mentioned voting to increase the the age
limit Reuters GOP house members are
threatening to force cuts to Medicare
and Social Security spending I mean
these are the facts this is from the
reporting that we all saw from you but
not you guys got that reporting because
of what you saw the actions were being
taken by House Republicans Washington
Post House Gopi Social Security Medicare
amid spending battle so this is
something that they have set over and
over again for the past several months
and there's also uh voting that could be
looked at on how they have treated this
issue of Medicare and Social Security so
they've been very vocal and they've been
very clear and so what we're going to do
is we're going to stand up for the
American people fight for the American
people and protect Medicare and Social
Security which the president has said
himself and been very clear about
sitting entitlements aside for a moment
loving other things Republicans are
saying is that there ought to be a
reduction in discretionary spending is
that something the president is in any
way open to or will he put forward a
budget on March 9th that increases
discretion so I'm not going to get into
get ahead of the President right as you
saw from our memo yesterday the
president's going to have his Budget on
March 9th he is calling and asking right
the speaker to put forward his budget as
well so the American people can see what
it is that they're thinking about what
it is that they're thinking about when
it comes to the American people and the
budget it right what what are the cuts
that they want to make what is it that
they're proposing so certainly not going
to get ahead of what the president's
going to put out on March 9th I just
could just because I know it's important
to everyone here and if we're to the
public as well can you explain the
decision not to offer the public
visibility on this meeting it's it's
tradition for the press to be brought in
when the president speaks to the speaker
of that no I'm look
not all the time the president has had
many conversations one-on-one
conversations with member of Congress
totally understand I get the question
and understand why there is interest in
this but we have done it many times
before where we've had private
one-on-one meetings with members of
Congress and not just in this
Administration we've seen it under
President Trump we've seen it under
President Obama and I know the the big
four was uh was there was a pull spray
for that one but it was the big four it
was a different kind of a different
meeting but it's not uncommon it is not
uncommon to have one-on-one private
one-on-one meetings and I'll just add to
this you know speaker speaker uh
McCarthy is is welcome to go to the
sticks after the meeting and take your
questions we we welcome that if that is
something that he wishes to do
uh can you help us just clarify what his
position then a little more is on
deficit reduction like you're saying
McCarthy hey give us your plan is your
plan the president has sort of let out
drips and grabs of his views here and
there
so just like frankly he is opposed to
any cuts to Medical security including
changes to eligibility he's open to
other spending Productions over the
medium term including potentially
defense I want to be very careful here
because what the president has been very
clear about is what is their plan he
wants to see their plan as it relates to
the budget right so the president's
going to put out his Budget on March 9th
you guys will all get to see that and so
we want to see what their plan is I'm
not going to to get ahead of that
particular piece when it comes to the
budget but of course the president's
going to protect the Medicare right of
for Americans of course the president is
going to do everything that he can to
protect Social Security and when it
comes to holding those two programs
hostage the president's going to call
that out and say that we should not be
holding those two uh those two programs
hostage on on something that is the
basic duty of Congress which is to lift
the debt ceiling something that they
should be able to do because it is their
constitutional Duty you're trying to put
this
what is their what is what are they
putting forth uh what is their idea of
uh dealing with the with fiscal right
fiscal uh priorities what does that look
like for them so that's what he's going
to ask them for which is what we did in
in our memo yesterday he wants to see
what is it that they're putting forward
we we want to see we have been very
clear when it comes to Medicare when it
comes to Social Security right that
should be protected we're going to
continue to fight for that and we've
been very clear when it comes to debt
limit it should be done without
conditions we've been very clear and we
should not hold those two programs and
others not just that hostage right been
very very clear about that on March 9th
the president's going to put forth his
budget you're going to see how he sees
the Budget moving forward in this uh in
this fiscal year and uh and so I'll
leave it there and then again as I said
in the memo you guys read it from Brian
D's and others that we want to see what
their plan is
see just just
the mid lift title 42 on May 11th when
the public health emergency
so I
look I just want to be very clear on
this part too because I know this
question has come up and I do want to do
a little bit of a step back here the CDC
said in April that the title 42 should
lift but the courts have as you all know
required us to keep it in place and so
that's kind of where we are so we do not
know when or what the courts will rule
but we we must comply with that order
and so we're going to comply with that
as it relates to what exactly is going
to happen because it is a court matter a
court order that is something that doj
is dealing with at this time even if you
let the emergency if the court order
hasn't been lifted you're going to keep
please so here's what we were trying to
do and I'll be uh explain like our
thinking here uh so what we're past
Republicans were trying to do is they
were trying to really Barrel toward
abruptly and immediately ending title 42
and what we are trying to do uh was to
make sure that there was an orderly
process to manage this in a in a really
uh it manage the situation at the Border
in a way that was uh again orderly and
effective and what they wanted to do is
to end something overnight which would
have created chaos and so that's why we
uh we are been very clear about doing
this when it comes to title 42 doing
this in a safe and orderly way and uh
and coming up uh you know we are putting
up we're putting forward alternative
priorities alternative ways to dealing
with the border and so that's why we
moved in that way that's why we were
very clear about uh about what we're
trying to do these next couple of months
now as you're asking me about the date
if it's going to happen or not on that
particular date again there's a court
order in place that as you know that was
that was very clear that doj is taking
on and so I would refer you to doj about
what will happen because of that court
order
thank you so much to domestic questions
today first of all when the president
meets with speaker McCarthy what are the
specific areas of bipartisan cooperation
that he's going to focus on aside from
you know the debt ceiling so there's
going to be a range of issues that
they're going to discuss you'll hear
from the president afterwards we'll have
a you know a readout of the meeting
you'll probably hear from the speaker if
he's if he is going to go to the sticks
you guys can all ask him questions don't
want to get ahead of a meeting that is
probably underway I believe and I just
don't want to get ahead of it but again
there'll be a range of issues that the
president thinks is important to work
with uh with uh with Congress on with
the speaker on but just don't want to
get ahead of what is going to be
discussed specifically zooming out on
The Tyree Nichols funeral today
both inside the United States and
outside are looking at this killing and
asking is the United States a racist
Society
I'd like to hear your thought on that
and also what the administration is
doing Beyond just police
qualified immunity those discussions
what the US is doing holistically what
the administration is doing
ballistically to address that perception
so at the top of the briefing you heard
me lay out how important this month is
because it's Black History Month and how
important it is to see black Americans
and lifting up the contribution of black
Americans and also understanding that
their culture when you think about Black
Culture as an American is also American
culture when you think about what
they've been able to what the black
community has been able to contribute to
the history of this country what they've
been able to contribute in many
different sectors of uh of America and
so that's something that's really
important that we will continue to lift
up there was a memorandum that was put
out by the president and look you know
when the president walked into this
Administration he said there were four
crises that we were needed to deal with
one of them was covid one of them was
the economy climate change and he talked
about race social injustice and he had
he had given many he has given many many
speeches on the work that we still need
to do to deal with an issue that is
affecting a community across communities
across the country this particular
Community the black community so we
understand he understands there's a lot
more work to be done and we need to call
out injustices and continue to do that
and while we have a rich history and an
important history in this country there
are things that he also believes is
important that we talk about and we
speak to and that is the injustices that
we have seen in the black community in
other communities as well historically
so that's why the president has made it
a priority in his administration to make
sure that it looks like America to make
sure that we see the diversity in this
Administration throughout different
communities and you see that over and
over again when you look at the
different agencies when you look into
the White House and this is this is not
historically the most diverse
Administration in history and that
matters when we talk about policies when
we're talking about transformational
change we talk about how do we move
forward in a country that is dealing
with many issues that's important to see
that and to have that at the federal
government so again lots more work to be
done the president understand that he's
spoken to that and we're going to
hopefully be able to uh to work towards
the healing for this country
thank you Karine I have two questions on
debt and deficit first the budget that
the White House proposed last year
represented 102 percent of the country's
economic output is the administration
aiming for something below that this
year I'm just not going to get ahead of
the president's uh budget that's coming
out on March 9th you'll be able to view
that once he's ready to speak to it but
directionally where our discussions I
hear you I hear you're asking me for
direction you're asking me what is it
potentially going to look like with the
ballpark number I'm just not going to
get ahead of the president and then on
the
2011 and now is the number of times that
Republicans have been able to pass the
debt limit on a clean basis without
anything attached to it but the other
difference is that the national debt has
more than doubled in that time it now is
about two hundred and forty thousand
dollars per household does the president
believe that that is sustainable well
let's let's remember why we have seen
that the last couple of years right I
mean we have seen that uh the it balloon
in the way that you just spoke to let's
not forget the Trump tax cut the two
trillion dollar 2017 Trump tax cut uh if
you think about that if you think about
the first piece of legislation that
Republicans put forward was going to
increase the limit by 100 billion
dollars and so there's been time after
time that we have seen uh you know uh
action that has been incredibly uh you
know not not uh prudent to what we need
to be doing and moving the country
forward the deficit increased every
single year under Trump his four years
in office are responsible for 25 percent
of total of our total national debt from
the last 230 plus years and so look
there's been action that's been taken by
by republicans in Congress that has led
to where we are today again their first
piece of legislation just weeks ago in
this new Congress would have would have
increased the deficit by a hundred
billion dollars and let's not forget uh
and let's not forget why to help tax
cheats wealthy tax cheats that's what
they wanted to do this is a president
for the first two years has taken
lowering the deficit very seriously and
has done it in a historic fashion well
this Administration pledged to be
deficit neutral this year but what I can
say is the president is committed to
dealing with lowering the deficit he he
has a record to to speak to as I just
mentioned the 1.7 billion dollars that
he's been able to do in the first two
years to lower the deficit and he is
willing willing to have a good faith
conversation right with uh with with
anybody Democrats Independents
Republicans to talk about how do we
continue to move forward to do that to
deliver uh a uh for the American people
yes on important programs and issues but
also how are we going to continue to
lower the deficit which he thinks is
incredibly important
Terry Nichols
as a member of Congress uh is would the
president meet with them when they're
here in town next week don't have a
don't have a meeting to preview at this
time as you know just last week last
Friday the president spoke with uh his
uh his mother and his stepfather
offering his condolences and saying that
uh telling telling them that he is going
to continue to fight for police reform
continue to fight for the George Floyd
policing act and so that is a commitment
that he's made to the family don't have
a don't have a meeting to to read out or
to announce at this time and on the
covid pandemic emergency the
Administration has been using that as
the justification for the plan to cancel
student loan debt does ending the covet
emergency undermine the student loan
plan so we see that very very
differently
um as uh as we we've talked about before
I think I've been asked this question
before so we're not using any emergency
power we're using the heroes act as I've
mentioned before which gives the
Secretary of Education the explicit
authority to provide by debt relief in
this exact situation so as you know
millions of Americans are are at risk to
default on their student loans due to
the economic effects of the National
Emergency and so this is why we took
this action to make sure that tens of
millions of Americans are able uh to uh
to deal with the time that was very
difficult especially in the last couple
of years so the secretary of education
is using the authority Congress gave
them to prevent the harm and so that's
been the important priority of the
president to make sure that the folks
who who felt the who felt um
felt the pinch if you will who felt the
hurt the most these past couple of years
due to what kova did to the economy got
a little extra help
with regards to the State of the Union
will that be paired with additional
travel and more broadly can you tell us
anything more about what the president
wants to accomplish legislatively over
the next year given the intense
Congressional gridlock so look on on the
first question we'll have more to share
on what uh what that week will look like
for the president again don't want to
get ahead of of any announcement from
here as far as legislatively look the
president has been very clear after
again after the midterms and this is a
president who's talked about throughout
his career working a bipartisan way with
Congress on delivering important
programs and important initiatives for
the American people that is something
that he's going to continue to do and it
won't stop him he's done that the first
two years I talked about 250 plus pieces
of legislation that's become law that
the president signed so clearly that's
something that the president is
committed to you know he's going to have
this conversation with speaker McCarthy
just like he's had a conversation last
week with the democr leaders and they're
going to try to figure out how can we
work together in a good faith way again
not going to get ahead of the
president's State of the Union speech
you'll hear from him you know you'll
hear from him talk about optimism talk
about possibilities which is something
that you've heard the president speak to
and how optimistic he is for the future
of this country he'll talk about you
know the his economic policy and how
it's delivered these last two years and
he'll lay out what his what he believed
his legislation plan is going to be for
the American people certainly not going
to get ahead of that at this time last
year on January 19th the president had a
solo press conference does the White
House anticipate that there will be a
press conference where reporters might
be able to ask him about those plans
that you just mentioned anytime in the
near future don't have a press
conference to to read out to you at this
time
okay thanks Karina of course Johnson is
in town talking about Aid to the Ukraine
it's he got to meet with the president
or anyone at the White House while he's
here don't have a meeting to read out at
this time or on the president's schedule
with the wood Boris Johnson
[Music]
student loans understanding that you
can't tell us why the FBI search the
Biden Center wasn't disclosed previously
and that Ian Sams has referred to
questions about the National Archives
possibly being blocked from sending a
press release to doj I understand you
can't talk about any of that can you
assure us that the White House has been
and continues to be as transparent as
possible meaning that where there
haven't been disclosures something has
prevented that what I can say is what
the president has said many times and
you've seen it in our statements is that
we are cooperating fully the president
his team is cooperating fully and we
will continue to do that and I'll just
leave it there on student loans does the
White House believe that the president
or Administration can continue to use
emergency Powers after the emergency is
over so providing uh debt debt relief or
pausing loan payments as it relates to
the student loans does not require an
ongoing and National Emergency and I
just laid out for Karen how we see this
process and talking about the heroes act
which was which was a Authority that was
given to the Secretary of Education
through Congress and that's how we're
moving forward there and look the
emergency and ending doesn't change the
legal justification and here's a couple
of things here there was a national
there was a National Emergency as we all
know as we've all lived through it
millions of borrowers were negatively
impacted by the pandemic and faced risk
of default on their loans due to that
emergency that National Emergency
Congress gave again the Secretary of
Education the authority to take steps to
prevent that harm and and he is and
that's how we see the process moving
forward with the heroes Act
the portion of the heroes act that the
secretary is using is the part that
needs a National Emergency to be able to
cancel that debt so I understand what
you're saying and it was sort of
explained in the background call a few
weeks ago on this where an official said
that the increased Authority Under
National Emergency is necessary for the
program to be created but doesn't have
to be in effect through the duration of
the program and the reason I'm asking is
that interpretation could potentially
allow for you know policy effectuation
beyond the emergency so at what point is
someone not worse off
after a pandemic how are we determining
I mean just getting back to I guess the
I guess the crust of your question is
that we don't need an emergency power to
use the heroes act it is a it is an
authority that was given to the
Secretary of Education and he's using
that Authority for a time for a moment
that we believe the American people
really need it after these last three
years after dealing with uh what what
many uh dealt with uh to dealt with a
you know a National Emergency that was
to them right something that was caused
them harm and so this is a way to help
tens of millions of Americans who need
election and a little extra help and so
that's what the secretary of education
is doing the heroes act that required
the National Emergency for the secretary
to use it and I know we're splitting
hairs here but
what I'm getting at is yes there was a
National Emergency yes the
administration used the heroes Act
because of the National Emergency to
cancel student debt and I understand
that the position that the
administration staked out in the doj
brief is that it doesn't have to be in
effect to do the program but my question
I'm getting at is when do you stop being
harmed by the pandemic how are we
measuring it and that's a good question
look it's not any and it's not any any
emergency power it is again something
that the Secretary of Education gets to
the heroes Act is something that is in
his purview that he's able to use an
authority that he's able to use and
that's a decision that the secretary of
education is going to make as you
remember the debt relief was uh was was
being used at the same time that we were
we were going to lift off the pause
right for uh for payments and so we
believe as that was going to happen we
needed to do something to help tens of
millions of Americans out there again
this is an authority that the secretary
of education has it's not just any kind
of emergency power this is a power that
was given to the Secretary of Education
uh by Congress that he's using in a way
to make sure that the Americans out
there who who have been harmed get a
little bit of extra relief
I really gotta move on
thank you
um does the president see the current
rate of spending at the federal level as
a problem and if so what spinning Cuts
would he
I mean look we I just talked about what
the president has done the last two
years right by lowering the deficit
right cutting the deficit by 1.7
trillion dollars so yes so that is
something that he took very seriously
and took action to make that happen if
you look at the inflation reduction act
the inflation reduction Act is going to
also lower the deficit by hundreds of
billions of dollars that is important as
well every piece of policy he's done it
in a really responsible way every
legislation that has been passed by
Congress that has been led by this
president he's done it in a responsible
way so yes he thinks it's important for
him to do his job and the best that he
can to really address the deficit and
and I'll add this I'll add this as well
and I've said this multiple times at
this Podium today which is that he is
willing he is willing to work in a
bipartisan fashion uh in a in a good
faith fashion with anybody from from
Congress who's willing to continue that
work that he has done to build on that
historic record that the president has
made so I'll leave it there thanks
everybody I'll see you tomorrow
let us know what time the McCarthy
meeting began